so school curriculum could not include  the word racism that's right because it  doesn't exist right it's a brain washing  technique to use to divide we are  americans we are america we are one  nation under god yeah and those words  tend to divide us would you ban and you  so you don't want any isms taught in  school  no racism no sexism no homophobia is um  no white supremacism and no  anti-semitism no ism is either right or  wrong good or evil now i'm sure you also  then would would say that when  republicans use the isms socialism and  communism that's also divisive right and  wrong because there is socialism look at  the democratic party  look at the mindset of most black people  they are socialists in their mind  in that they allow the government to do  for them  and tell them when and where and how